umgangsformen 4.0 tipps von professor
thomas schäfer elmayer heute richtig
durch die tür
ja wenn man auf eine tür zugeht alleine
wird man ja wahrscheinlich gar kein
problem haben dadurch zu gehen aber wenn
man in begleitung einer ranghöheren
person durch eine türe geht da gibt es
mehrere probleme unter umständen man
sollte eine türe die man zu sich hier
ziehen kann
immerzu sich herziehen und der
ranghöheren person erlauben vor einem
durchzugehen
wenn die türe aber von mir weg aufgeht
dann gehe ich zuerst durchhalte die tür
auf der anderen seite auf und lasse dann
die ranghöhere personen durchgehen